you know sometimes politics is
relatively friendly
relatively it's the key word here is
relatively sometimes it's truly
vicious we are much closer to the latter
end of things at the moment
anderson cooper sums this up on cnn
when anderson cooper was talking about
you know unity and healing and how we
need to be inclusive and tolerant we
can't otherwise people
as he compares
basically every republican to the the
worst
sort of killers
genocidal maniacs most vicious people in
the history of the world
you know part of it i think just based
on what you were just saying
it comes to mind the idea of otherizing
people is something i think we saw a lot
of over the last four years i mean
something we've seen a lot over the last
decades but it's so easy to otherwise
people to make people other than other
than american other than patriotic other
than human
you know and we've seen it in bosnia
we've seen it in rwanda where radio was
telling
people the you know hutus were telling
the radio listeners that tootsie were
cockroaches
for you know getting them jinned up for
genocide
um and you see it in in these videos
where
people who claim they are patriots are
in the face of a police officer calling
him
uh you know as we're seeing it right
there yeah gosh could you imagine if the
left ever said anything mean to or about
the police
you know like all of 2020 no but that
forget about that we're just talking
about the republicans for a moment here
because
you see we don't want to otherwise
we don't want to other the republicans
are otherwising people you know as awful
vicious deplorable irredeemable
republicans
those neo-nazis there they are other
rising people
you know those republicans who are who
are just like the genocidal regime
in rwanda you know them those people
they have nothing redeeming about them
and we need to ostracize them from the
country they're so evil and terrible
they're otherwising people you see and
it's very bad to otherize people
why if you otherwise people you'd be
like those republican cockroaches
who need to be rooted out pull them out
of the country darn it
does anderson cooper not know what he's
saying he probably knows what he's
saying he probably knows
how ironic what he's saying is but he
doesn't care he's just he is other
rising people right he's projecting in
the way the left always projects
and these snakes these snake republicans
want to join i'm talking about the real
snake republicans i'm otherwising mitt
romney
and company they are joining in an
unconstitute
unconstitutional proceeding aimed at not
just donald trump but aimed at all
the rest of us if you enjoyed that video
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content
out there
[Music]
you